help us change the culture by buying our
latest single from tim cast records only
ever wanted by clicking the link in the
description below
i want to jump to the story from the
post millennial oh it's us again drafer
bomb threat at boston children's
hospital ruled false police report no
suspicious items were observed or
located an incident report from the
boston police department specifies i
also want to say that my initial
assessment here was that it was a hoax
and a hoax
but now it appears it's a hoax hoax at a
hoax
so i'll explain and then i'll throw it
to billboard chris but the first story
is clearly the bomb threat itself was
was clearly fake
but also the police did not even show up
until an hour and 20 minutes after the
call came in and they did not clear the
the the area until an hour or about an
hour later so i'm like okay the police
weren't even taking it seriously it was
around eight o'clock that the call came
in 9 20 where the police actually showed
up and then 10 o'clock when they
actually cleared the the space out so
you have the hoax of the call itself
you have the hoax of the media narrative
that everything got shut down and now
what's the latest so yeah there's a
couple employees there that send me the
emails they're getting so i get those
but then this employee told me
the weird thing is that they never sent
out an initial lockdown email only the
all clear one no added security this
morning either and this whole time the
last two weeks there's been no added
security no one in the hospital has been
getting any threats that this employee
knows of most people didn't even know
that i had tweeted out all these videos
originally they're just playing victim
trying to shift the narrative away from
their own words that everyone heard in
the videos that i tweeted out and
they're trying to make themselves into a
victim
but
there's really not that much going on
there what are their own news you
tweeted is that stuff
about youtube yeah it's all these so
they were on youtube these videos were
on youtube they had all these they took
them down yeah they had all these videos
on their youtube channel and
i was alerted to one of it one of them
so i tweeted it out it was about gender
affirming hysterectomies
how they will cut out the uterus of a
girl or young woman to affirm her gender
and it started to take off post
millennial wrote about it
and
i thought i better record this because
it's getting some steam going here
and of course they deleted the video so
then i tweeted out my recorded version
of it i sent it to libsytic talk i sent
it to matt walsh they retweeted it for
me it went viral
and in the meantime i recorded about 40
other videos from their youtube site
that they have also deleted all of those
now are they still doing gender
affirming hysterectomies at the hospital
yeah and they even they even changed
their website they had a page talking
about how they do phalloplasties
on 17 year olds or sorry vaginoplasties
so this is yeah it was the vaginoplasty
yeah 17 year olds yeah this is where
they create a neo vagina for young men
or boys they castrate them and then
invert the penis
it gets gruesome guys but anyway they
changed their website it used to it used
to say 17 year olds now it says 18 year
olds they also claim that they follow
the wpath standards of care so wpath is
the world professional association for
transgender health they write the
standards of care that these gender
clinics can follow if they feel like it
but wpath is lowering the age for all of
these surgeries right now and their new
standards of care coming out next week
and in there they recommend womb removal
and testicle removal for 17 year olds
breast removal for 15 year olds
but a lot of these clinics are going
even younger than that i have kellen
lockhart on video from kaiser permanente
in oakland california admitting that
they cut off the breasts of a 12 year
old girl
and they're castrating 16 year old boys
we have lots of stories like this these
places are out of control there's no
regulation but humans love boobs that's
the crazy thing right that it it but
it's true what what was this look libby
well
but i mean like but these gender clinics
treat them as expendable like if someone
wanted to cut off their foot we wouldn't
cut off their foot what what i mean is
um
like there was the anyway i i may be
wrong but i'm pretty sure that humans
are the only mammalian species with
permanently swollen breasts i believe so
i believe that's true uh so most most
mammals only start producing and you
know their breasts only in gorge when
they're child rearing but humans are
different that's what i mean like humans
love boobs
and so it's the it's it's this
interesting thing just to see that
they're telling children that these are
bad things that you should get rid of
and they're performing mastectomies on
minor girls yeah we've got johanna olsen
kennedy who's one of the top specialists
in the world who runs the gender gender
clinic at children's hospital los
angeles she's on video talking about a
13 year old girl who got her breasts cut
off and she says what's the big deal
if they want to get breasts when they're
older they can just go buy them you also
have what do they think breasts are
right you also have doctors on tick tock
saying that they're going to eat the
teats and it's that's what that's what
they say
they're like i'm going to eat teats
tomorrow it's very exciting and they get
all into it uh olsen kennedy was also i
think the doctor um a doctor who was
treating
the child of an abc executive who was at
disney who was then advocating against
the parental rights and education bill
she also get this guys
she applied for a grant and was given a
grant it went to four hospitals
the nih national institute of health
gave 5.7 million dollars to four
different children's hospitals as part
of the grant they reduced the age that
these kids could receive the opposite
sex hormones
so this is girls getting testosterone or
boys getting estrogen well
they reduced the age as part of this
grant from 13 years of age to 8 years
old but but i also want to make sure
we're clarifying here they're not
actually giving kids testosterone or
estrogen they're giving them pseudo
right it's a it's a it's a faux it's not
actual human hormones well yeah
synthetic testosterone right right i
don't know how they produce it but yeah
but but so this is an important factor
because um for a long time i thought
they were giving legitimate human
hormones to children
they're not it's synthetic or it comes
from animals or things like that there
have been uh older trans people who have
advocated for like like horse estrogen
or something like that i've seen posted
on forums
so what i end up reading is that some of
these kids end up with very serious
ailments based on the hormones they're
getting because they're not quite the
same
i think one one example of uh some
because i'm not a bio a biologist or a
chemist or anything like that but uh
people talk about soy and how soy
feminizes people but i believe soy is
phytoestrogen which is it's a different
form it's like less potent or something
like that that i'm not i'm not saying
necessarily what that means other than
there are different kinds of estrogen
that affect the body in similar ways but
they are different
okay yeah and plus it doesn't belong in
their body like they have a small amount
of testosterone girls do naturally but
they're getting dosages that are 20
times what they're supposed to have but
what i mean is if you give a human being
if a human being's body produces human
testosterone then the body reacts to it
but i'd imagine if you give a human
being horse testosterone or some other
synthetic it's going to react
differently than it would to actual
testosterone right but perhaps similarly
and we don't know because this whole
thing is a giant experiment right it's
never been done in the history of the
world
whether you believe in god or you
believe in evolution well obviously if
you believe in god you're saying god
made us wrong by doing this to kids and
if you believe in evolution as i do well
we've evolved over about a billion years
humans have been on this planet only for
maybe 300 000 years
but are we to believe now that for the
first time in human history in this
little 10-year window
that a pharmaceutical company is here to
help our children be who they really are
you don't trust pharmaceutical companies
evolution got it all wrong
you know i love this notion that the
left used to like 10 years ago they were
like these big pharma is bad and now
they're like big farmers good my friend
well it's all part of a piece too
because you have on the uh
at boston children's one of the
founders of the gender clinic there was
pioneering the use of puberty blockers
and younger kids
and that was something
i think that was started in like 2013 or
something like that boston children's as
part of their promotional
materials was showing profiles of kids
who
came to the clinic specifically for uh
being young and being cared for in this
way at that clinic and they talk about
how they have to go into the hospital a
lot and they talk about this as a
positive thing you know they know right
why who i am and why i'm there they have
to get bone density scans they have to
get brain scans and all of this stuff
puberty blockers
yeah
there's a lot of concerns also the
makers of these drugs don't recommend
that you be on them for more than like
three or four months and kids are going
on them for years at a time and then
being ushered onto cross-sex hormones so
that's an issue as well and the way that
the the trans kids are promoted i think
is also really
a dangerous thing because they look so
happy and smiling and it's like
yeah you look great for these photo ops
you know like
but let's see what's really going on why
do you need brain scans and bone scans
and yeah 20 20-year prediction
oh this is done
you think it'll be gone there'll be no
more way before that way before that but
what about what about these people
they're home for life
they are literally lifetime medical
patients
when you cut out the womb of a girl
sometimes they cut out just the uterus
sometimes they cut out the ovaries as
well
so if this girl gets a little older she
gets to be 25 years of age her brain's
finished developing now she says what
the heck did you do to me i have all
these medical complications she's gone
through menopause yeah you cut out their
ovaries sometimes that's instant
menopause that has a hundred side
effects of its own early onset dementia
osteoporosis all sorts of issues a young
woman in dc messaged me two days ago she
she was rushed to the er three times
because she's on testosterone and it was
damaging her kidneys wow
i heard that that causes the blood to
thicken up too
there's so many things and we don't even
know them all you mentioned vision loss
the fda just three or four weeks ago
issued a warning saying that these kids
brains are swelling up and they're
suffering permanent vision loss this is
news a young girl in sweden suffered
spinal fractures while she was on
puberty blockers 12 other kids there
at the karolinska hospital suffered
catastrophic injuries and they've
stopped this in sweden they've stopped
it in finland tavistock in the uk in
england they're shutting down the
tavistock which is the only gender
clinic they are spreading it out though
and making it regional yeah but they're
it's going to be they're going to
totally redo how it's going on and it's
not going to be nearly as extreme
i just want to mention one more thing
what never gets talked about enough
at the tavistock where we have good
statistics because there was only one
gender clinic that all the kids went to
in england
35 of the children had moderate to
severe autism
that number goes above 50 when you
include the mild cases and all these
children's hospitals here in the u.s
have partnerships with autism
organizations it's like providing a
funnel of kids for them and if you look
at the children's national hospital
website in dc where i was just at
yesterday two days ago
right on their website they have a
gender autism program and it states
right on their website that they don't
yet know why so many autistic kids
experience gender nonconformity
but that doesn't stop them from
sterilizing them why do you think they
experience gender non-conformity
autistic kids from all the parents i've
spoken to these kids already feel like
they don't fit in
they tend to obsess over things
they're feeling like they don't fit in
and this ideology's coming along and
it's being presented as
the cure for them that it's because
they're trapped in the wrong body which
is why they don't feel like a typical
girl
and that by transitioning this is going
to solve all their problems but all
these kids at these gender clinics have
comorbidities going on they've got
autism some of them will go grow up to
be gay
all of our studies into gender dysphoria
show that 80 to 90 of the time
when kids went through puberty it
desisted and the majority of them were
gay the most recent study that came out
followed 139 boys from about the age of
five all the way into their twenties
eighty seven point eight percent of them
they just grew out of it sixty four
percent grew up to be gay
so in addition to all the other harm
that's going on this is actually a
deeply homophobic movement that's
telling kids just because they don't
conform to stereotypes that this must
mean they're trapped in the wrong body
and my message is one of body positivity
if a girl wants to climb trees play in
the dirt throw around a football hates
wearing dresses and wants to have short
hair guess what she's 100 girl
it doesn't mean she's a boy
i mean she's a weird thing this uh this
movement just reinforces gender
stereotypes it sure does it's all it is
they call it they call it social
constructs but then if someone exhibits
what is clearly as they describe a
social construct they say well i gotta
get surgery and drugs right which
doesn't really make a whole lot of sense
now does it no it's not what if the
stereotypes of society change yeah
i mean
people in scotland wear skirts yeah i
mean this dog
what if like some kid from scotland
comes over and they're like he's wearing
a skirt oh get the surgery ready so we
already chopped his nuts off sorry
right yikes so these doctors at boston
children's hospital in their own videos
we have this doctor
saying that if a little girl little
toddler girl tries to pee standing up
that's a sign she's a boy
if a little boy doesn't want to get a
haircut that's a sign he's a girl she
literally states in this video that toys
are one of the determining factors
in our gender well and she's not the
only one this is being they're always
doctors all over the place you know if
your child wants to play with drugs and
maybe they're not the gender that you
think they are
and they talk about how kids very young
ages can express that they're in the
wrong bodies before they even know what
a body is necessarily it's also
interesting too that american kids are
prescribed psych drugs like one in 12
american kids
as on a psychiatric medication most of
these have not been fda approved for
kids under 18 as well
you have a lot of kids who are on these
drugs they're on multiple they're on
like major drug cocktails of these
things that are not approved
for
kids um and you also have a lot of the
kids who are being prescribed these
drugs are boys who are
like lower class boys who have had
multiple child abuse issues as well and
they're being given
masses of
psych and behavioral drugs it's very
weird what i think
it's very weird what we do to our kids
like and we keep we've been talking
about that a lot tonight i think
between all of the different kinds of
drugs and medications telling them what
we think they are
what we think they're about we're not
educating them properly we're just
trying to indoctrinate that it's so
weird like we don't let kids exist
there's also the inverse
where i saw these these uh pamphlets
where they're like let your children be
who they are and it's kind of like i
mean you're the parent you got to help
the kid become who they're going to be
right and you have to reinforce them
positively as well so i'll say
it's not a blanket moral logic statement
that indoctrination is bad
indoctrination is a reference to
typically instilling children with
harmful things with values that are
going to do them do them wrong in life
but but well so the idea is seating you
could you could technically use a word
in a similar way if you're going to
instill within your child values that
will help them survive and and be happy
and flourish you are instilling values
into them that are good what these
parents are doing is either not
instilling any values letting your kid
be who they are let your child tell you
it's like
i've heard a lot of things from a lot of
kids that don't make sense you know
also what happens when that kid tells
you something tells you they are
something that you don't like like a
like a rock like a rock or a cat or i'm
a giraffe or a conservative i am now you
know thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there